and don't put it upside down to dip just  will fall off dip only the fish part  into the sauce okay and I put the whole  thing in my mouth this feels so sexual  already mmm it's delicious no matter  what you do  zero present different than how I  usually eat sushi it's fun to eat things  with your hands up be putting the fish  right on my tongue kind of enhance the  taste experience because it is straight  to the taste buttons when you put it in  rice first the the rice bits are gonna  fall down and so you'll just be picking  them out of the soy sauce step control  it's important in sushi how are you  supposed to eat ginger is there a  certain way upside down